on les voit parler des documents on
arrive depuis février ramata et
volontaire auprès d'une association
elle donne des cours de français à des
étrangers pour faciliter leur
intégration
cette année comme plus de 850 yvelinois
âgés de 16 à 25 ans elle est engagée
dans un service civique
quand jd mon petit frère à faire ses
devoirs j'étais quelqu'un qui sont hervé
trop vite donc avec eux j'ai fait petit
à petit j'ai appris à canaliser et
éviter de m'énerver vite du coup j'ai
pris confiance en moi je me suis dis
papa besoin de ce que de 2,5 était donc
ça va venir petit à petit je fais de la
médiation numérique et j'essaie de
réparer ce qu'on appelle la fracture
numérique
l'exclusion numérique c'est une mission
très utile je me sens très utile dans ce
que je fais solidarité éducation
environnement culture ou sport un
engagement au service de l'intérêt
général auprès de collectivités
territoriales d'établissements publics
ou services de l'état pour une durée de
6 à 12 mois
indemnisés 580 euros par mois
le service civique est un premier pas
dans la socialisation le seuil fixé par
l'emploi c'est pas un stage mais c'est
vrai qu'on est à la limite 1 du travail
puisque le jeune considère que my va
travailler en fait le matin et doit se
lever il travaille dans une équipe il a
un cadre il a un chef qui lui donne des
ordres
et ça ça était bien dit tout à l'heure
par certains jeunes et du coup c'est
vraiment un tremplin pour moi pour
l'insertion sociale au sens général
n'ont qu'à la fois aux professionnels
mais aussi social mis en place en 2010
par le gouvernement le service civique a
déjà permis à plus de 3000 jeunes
yvelinois de participer à une mission